dass das bild live schönen guten morgen
an diesem mittwoch der mit der traurigen
gewissheit beginnt der in bayern so
verzweifelt gesuchte tobias ist tot wir
waren noch mit der hoffnung ins bett
gegangen dass er lebend gefunden wird
mithilfe all seine freunde die einfach
nicht glauben konnten dass es seitdem
gemeinsam feiern am freitag keine spur
mehr von ihm gibt mit hilfe der polizei
die eine riesige suchaktion gestartet
hatte aber tobias lebt nicht mehr
so jung erst 25 jahre alt und plötzlich
tot tobias aus dem bayerischen eching
der fröhliche gut aussehender junger
mann mit lederhose verschwunden seit
freitag seine engsten freunde sie haben
verzweifelt nach ihnen gesucht nicht
gefunden wir treffen uns heute wieder
zum suchen brauchen natürlich so viel
hilfe wie möglich doch es gibt keine
spur die tage vergehen ohne hinweise auf
tobias sein letztes lebenszeichen beim
brass wiesen festival am echinger see im
landkreis freising
gemeinsames feiern gemeinsames trinken
dann zieht ein schweres gewitter auf das
festival wird aus sicherheitsgründen
abgebrochen tausende machen sich schnell
gleichzeitig auf den heimweg tobias
freunde verlieren ihnen der anger aus
den augen wenig später bricht auch der
telefonische kontakt zu ihm ab ab 22.30
ist sein handy aus er wird noch einmal
gesehen am eingang zum campingplatz
stark betrunken mit schürfwunden an den
abend so heißt das dann nichts mehr die
polizei ermittelt eine große suche läuft
an hubschrauber wasserwacht feuerwehr
und rettungshundestaffel doch von tobias
fehlt jede spur
bis dienstagabend dann die traurige
gewissheit tobias ist tot seine leiche
wird von einem schwimmer im echinger see
gefunden
und wir sprechen mit kalk heim der diese
suche nach tobias in den vergangenen
tagen so eng begleitet hat unser bild
reporter größe dich karl diese nachricht
die bricht jetzt das herz erst recht
nachdem wir all die freunde von tobias
ja gesehen haben die ihnen so
verzweifelt gesucht haben in den letzten
tagen hier muss eine welt
zusammengebrochen seien
ja du sagst es keine hat es mitbekommen
das ist in sozialen netzwerken durch
ganz deutschland gegangen wurde vielfach
geteilt millionenfach geteilt diese
aufrufe auch freunde und bekannte von
mir haben das geteilt bei instagram oder
auch bei facebook ja und jetzt ja diese
treuen gewissheit dass er tot ist
da gibt es irgendwelche hinweise wie
tobias ums leben gekommen es gibt es
hinweise auf ein gewaltverbrechen
nach dem derzeitigen stand gibt es daher
keine hinweise dass es sich um ein
gewaltverbrechen um sogenanntes
fremdverschulden handelt man geht die
polizei geht von einem klassischen
unfall aus er war er stark alkoholisiert
hatte er noch mal dagegen kurz vor 23
uhr sich ein neues bier gekauft soll
nach zeugenaussagen auch tatsächlich sie
ist gerade eben noch so auf den beinen
halten können und dann tatsächlich
verliert sich die spur man hat die groß
abgesucht alles interessanterweise ist
hier auch über diesen echinger see wo er
dann hinter mir gefunden wurde auch am
montag einer der acht
polizeihubschrauber drüber geflogen der
hatte hier allerdings nichts entdeckt
und erst gestern abend der so gegen 18
45 hat ein schwimmer diese grausame
entdeckung gemacht dass hier plötzlich
eine männliche leiche im auf der
wasseroberfläche schwimmt und dann hat
man relativ zügig feststellen können
dass es sich um tobias handelt die
kleidung das aussieht und auch
persönliche gegenstände passten dazu ich
gehe davon aus dass die
staatsanwaltschaft landshut eine
obduktion anordnen wird um auch ganz
sicher ausschließen zu können dass sie
sich nicht doch um ein
fremdverschulden handelt aber nach dem
jetzigen nach dem jetzigen stand geht
man hier von einem tragischen unfall aus
der fall war so seltsam weil man ja
gemeinsam gefeiert hatte und dann sich
jede spur von diesem 25 jährigen
plötzlich verlor und dieser fall war
auch so besonders weil eben die freunde
so intensiv gesucht haben und so
emotionale videos gepostet haben eine
eigene anlaufstelle gegründet haben für
hinweise was hörst du dort aus dem
umfeld jetzt von tobias kann
also bisher hat man sich aus dem um
heldt noch nicht geäußert der die
familie die freunde werden von einem
kriseninterventionsteam betreut das ist
natürlich auch ein riesengroßer schock
man hat zuletzt gehofft bis zuletzt
gehofft dass man ihn neben finden wird
ja diese hoffnung die schwindende dann
immer mit je länger das dann halt
gedauert hat das hat auch die polizei
gesagt je länger das dauert desto
geringer ist die chance im leben zu
finden
es bleibt abzuwarten wie jetzt ob es
dann noch mal ein statement geben wir
weil es waren tatsächlich sehr sehr
viele freunde bekannte oder auch einfach
nur leute die das bei bild gesehen haben
oder bei anderen medien oder diese
aufrufe die einfach mitzuhelfen die
ihnen gar nicht kannten die dann 40
gestern am see aufgetaucht sind sohn
gesagt haben menschen wollen hier
einfach mit helfen wir wollen wir helfen
tobias leben zu finden ja jetzt diese
selben schreckliche gewissheit dass
diese hilfe ja nichts gebracht hat danke
kelkheim unser bild reporter dort in
eching am echinger see wo man eben jetzt
die leiche vom 25 jahre alten tobias
gefunden hat die traurige gewissheit
unsere gedanken sind heute mit der
familie von tobias
[Musik]